me and my girl gotta embrace the fact
that girls love me because we out here
um selling eyelashes and lip gloss and
all that so yeah i'm just gonna get to
that you feel me i i i'm like molding my
girl into a business woman herself you
feel me yeah talk about whose idea was
it to do the eyelashes and lip gloss
so it was
it like came came about together like
she was getting eyelashes and i'm like
yo what's the price on that we start
talking and chopping it up and i'm like
yo we need to do this and then she
creatively designed all the girl stuff
she she's super creative so she'd be
coming up with everything and i'll just
be throwing the ideas out there like
what we could do and then [ __ ] she
[ __ ] put the stamp on it oh she's the
first rapper with his own eyelashes yeah
come on and they look nice as [ __ ] yeah
i gotta go cop slam with jesus ladies
tap in tap the [ __ ] in and you got lip
gloss yeah lip gloss all that that's
like mc magic pulled up here once and
this [ __ ] had his own makeup
palettes
hey man i'm gonna get i'm gonna get into
all that man you see
you see what um what's your name kylie
kylie jenner and rihanna's a billionaire
off of makeup bro not even the music the
[ __ ] i'm talking about like the music is
just like a vessel for everything else
yeah